Hello Freak bitches.
Isn't it amazing that we even have what's legal and what's not legal?
I mean,
what does that mean?
Wrote it down on paper.
We all agreed.
I mean thinking about the shit that isn't isn't illegal and the fact that war is
on that list at all.
I had like laws.
Do you like what wants you can't beat the shit out of him.
He
can't come into my house to take my stuff.
What am I going to do?
What am I honestly going to do about it?
I was thinking about that when I was watching the UFC this past weekend.
I was watching this,
a frightful beating that Alexander Gustafson put on glover to share and it was
just a ruthless knockout,
just fucking vicious beat down and then eventually stopped him and I was
thinking,
it's kind of crazy that these guys agree to do this.
They agree to do this.
Everybody signs away and then you go do something that anywhere else in the
world you would get locked down for.
The rest of that happens in hockey every once in awhile where somebody goes too
far and then the government gets involved.
Really?
Yeah.
Like what do they do if you hit somebody in the head with a stick goes outside
the boundaries of a setting.
The tone.
That seems like a pussy move though.
Hit Him with a stick.
You're supposed to punch.
Well,
it's so weird when you got this stick in your hand.
You know it,
it just the shit that you sometimes think of doing.
I would bury each other and the balls.
They fucking whack at the bay.
There's no padding behind your legs.
Just imagine that just taken up would stick it just ah,
with NHL level strength and just given someone a two hander the backlight,
they break people's finger.
Crosby almost took somebody's finger off this year.
If they get too far,
like if the.
If it gets really.
If they just opened the rules up a little bit.
You know what's gonna Happen?
They're gonna.
Bring in figure skaters and they going to teach them taekwondo.
I'm going to cut people's fucking heads off with the skates.
Dude.
You're spinning elk man.
If you ever learned how to skate,
you'd be fucking dangerous.
If you have a did that with skates on,
that would be it.
That's what I'm saying.
If you teach that to somebody,
teach that to somebody with skates.
I mean if you could hit someone with a hockey stick,
why can't you hit them with skate?
Like where were you on the line?
He can't hit them with this that they do it.
Somebody does it to you.
I know they slashed and they do stuff like that.
You can't club somebody over.
I mean even slashing so.
Okay.
I'll just slash your leg out.
What would you rather have?
Would you rather have ticket get hit by a piece of wood and you don't have a
bruise there or have somebody slash you with escape?
I would absolutely rather get hit by the piece of wood,
but I shouldn't get hit by the piece of wood.
I don't.
I don't play hockey,
but if I did play hockey I'd be pretty pissed.
If somebody hit me with a stick,
I'd be like,
you fucking pussy and I'd want to hit.
It became like the second coming of Thai Domi you have the exact same build.
He's a fucking guy who somehow was like my height and was considered a
heavyweight fighter and he's the guy according to him,
he came up with the,
grab them by,
right,
right underneath your collar and then turn all the way sideways because he
didn't have the reach advantage.
Oh.
And then he would,
he would wait for them to throw he duck under and then come over the top.
And Dude,
I,
I met him one time,
great fucking guy.
And he,
he's got these as like your hands use your hands.
You make like that.
It turns into a hammer.
It's the same thing.
He has like these inexplicably like bare fucking pause and I might be a little
taller than him.
And I remember when he's tried to show me when he grabbed the front of my shirt
to show me,
like,
I literally felt like an adrenaline,
like a flashback.
I hope this guy doesn't snap.
Now he's one of the,
like,
he's,
he's one of the toughest guys that ever you ever played?
Uh,
there's some girls in Portland that had taken a rash of shit because they're
selling burritos and they're white.
They made a burrito truck and people are going crazy trying to shut them down,
shut them down because they're not Mexican and they're selling burritos like
they're not.
They're not pretending.
They're not like putting shoe Polish on and pretending.
And I put in Brown face on there just fucking selling burritos.
Like it's so crazy.
Critics close,
white women's Portland Burrito stand for cultural theft.
What the fuck man?
Their burritos assholes next against.
Don't even even free to just.
They do.
You mentioned a Mexican expert Burritos A.
I've eaten Burritos in Mexico.
Yes.
I have had a real chicken burrito in Mexico and was quite delicious.
I love Mexico.
I just don't understand why anybody thinks that there's something wrong with
learning a style of cooking.
It's like,
I think if you have cultural appropriation,
if you have like a person who's pretending they're from Laos and they start
talking with the fake accent and you know,
and you go,
hey man,
you're full fucking Cleveland.
You're not even.
You're not even have Laos to scent like you do at 23 and me on you and you find
out like your family is from Finland,
like the fuck is wrong with you.
Like,
but there are people that do that and that is crazy.
Right?
But that's just deceptive.
This is not deceptive.
Someone who likes making Burritos,
they're making burritos and then these goofy white kids are fucking closing them
down.
And that's what it is.
Cultural Appropriation,
heroes just shouting out from the rooftop that you're wrong,
you're wrong.
It's like you said,
we're just always looking for who to blame,
who to be mad at,
who to make sort of the,
the persecutor of our felt wrongness.
It's that same issue.
Wow.
We premiered last night and it will air this Sunday.
And uh,
Jim Carey said some amazing things,
man.
Yeah.
That's our cast photo.
That one that you clicked that one.
Yeah.
Did it feel weird to beyond that?
I mean,
it must have been like,
I can tell you from the bottom of my heart,
it was the most important thing I've done so far.
Wow,
dude.
I mean,
we're paying homage to the world that,
that we love and respect so much and it was a big effort on Jim's part and his
producing partner,
Michael Aguilar to like tell real stories.
A lot of the stories that people will see if you watch the show and I hope you
do come from Jim's real life to dudes from Boston moved.
They live in a fucking dude's closet in West Hollywood and they used to be a guy
that would jerk off and watched him change him,
put that story in the show man.
He wanted all these little great tidbits.
There's a great moment about jokes dealing in there and a fucking huge fist
fight that breaks out.
That was real from Jim's personal life about guys who used to come in from the
fucking radio,
from talk radio in the morning.
They come to the club at night,
come to the store,
steal shit.
The next morning comics would fucking hear it.
Yeah.
That's a real common thing and that was always going on.
You know what else was going on?
A big one was a writers for sitcoms would come same shit and they would watch
people do sets and then they would wind up putting their,
their bits and like even on fucking Seinfeld kept wanting.
Kevin James Signature bits got used on Seinfeld after he had a bunch of meetings
and then they came to see him perform.
A bunch of top writers came to see him performing and NBC showcase.
It was only when Kevin was getting a development deal and they came down and
watched him and then like the next season his muffin bit was on a Seinfeld
episode.
It was like,
what the fuck man?
Well nowadays they fucking.
They're blatantly tell you,
like I tested for Saturday night live and you sign a form that says these
characters can be used after the audition.
Whoa,
and this is crazy.
I'm not calling out anybody or saying anything,
but they did.
There was a character ended up on the show that Vanessa Bayer did fucking
hilariously,
that I did something similar in my audition.
I was like,
damn,
that was really good.
It's me.
So you,
you audition,
you have a character.
You audition with,
yeah,
I did this character at is fake.
They can steal that.
They own that now.
Cause you audition,
you audition,
you surrender the character.
Fuck you man.
Yeah,
you sign a piece of paper,
man.
It's crazy to not even giving you money and they're stealing your idea when you
get there.
That's the respect that,
uh,
the SNL has earned in the community.
You don't,
you don't have that respect.
It's crazy that stealing.
You're stealing while I signed the form,
man.
Oh my God,
that's so awful.
I signed that shit because of the.
Because you can almost taste it,
you know,
they're making you sign something saying we're going to steal from you.
Totally.
So there was an instance where a faculty member,
I'm accused those that were challenging any of these equity proposals as being
part of a racist backlash.
And she was clearly talking about me because I'm the most,
um,
the most prominent a person objects as faculty member,
a white person or no.
Um,
so anyway,
she says in a faculty meeting that,
uh,
this is a racist backlash.
And I said to her in front of this faculty meeting,
I said,
somebody might want to check on the question of whether or not I'm actually a
racist,
because if you do check on it,
um,
you will discover I'm not,
and if you don't,
this is going to blow up on you.
And the chair of the Faculty told me that the faculty meeting was not the place
to defend myself against accusations of racism.
I said to her,
that's fine.
Where is not the place to level to level the accusations.
But I said,
where is the place?
And then the faculty member who had made the accusation said,
you should not expect there to be a venue in which to defend yourself.
You should just get used to these accusations.
In a separate case.
I was telling who said that a white guy or oh,
it's the same faculty member who made the accusation,
wait a minute,
the person said that you should just accept these untrue accusations.
Yes.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
what's your reaction to that?
That this is not a place for you to defend yourself against racist accusations.
This is a place for you to just eat shit,
right?
You just have to accept these accusations on a separate occasion.
We were also told that,
um,
that to question,
uh,
an allegation of racism is racist.
Oh,
so convenient.
Yeah.
We'll try to wrap your mind around that.
One question and accusation of racism is racist,
right?
We have an obligation to believe.
Wow.
I know.